I don't know about you guys but I have
been living life to its fullest you know
what that means it means I have gout
that's what that means
yeah it turns out there's some side
effects to live in life to its fullest
and one of those things is goat
whoops too full it's a pretty dumb
disease I panicked I went to the doctor
all freaked out like oh my god I've gone
I can't believe I've disease I'm now an
unhealthy person and I was so worried
and my doctors like settle down a lot of
people have gout it's easily manageable
Kyle all you have to do is just avoid
beer and any food you might find at a
barbecue all I heard was you're gonna
die that's yeah for the kid it's it's so
stupid like you get it just from living
pleasure you get it from just eating and
drinking whatever you want that's what
happens and I did that you just get it's
a dump you get it from just living Oh
fun a little bit reckless and then
you're saddled with something forever
how unfair is that having a good time a
little irresponsibility and boom now
you've got it's like herpes but at least
you got laid to get herpes at least the
universe gave you that consideration you
know you could be mad that you got
herpes but then you remember how you got
herpes you're like oh yeah
I didn't get laid you know what I got I
got too many menu items with the word
rodeo in the description oh my god
that's not even a flavor that's that's
just the food telling you to hold on and
I fall forward every time what so this
wants to last through my taste buds will
wrestle me up a half dozen of them dumb
disease that's befitting I deserve it
I'm a dumb guy dumb three weeks ago I
entered nachos as an uber destination
you ever think you're living further in
the future than you really are here come
on I just updated my phone let's go
robot bring me two snacks works like I
believe in aliens that's not even a dumb
part the Templars I don't have proof I'm
just going with my heart the closest
thing I have to proof of aliens is one
time in Chicago I got in a cab and
before I could even spin out my address
to the driver of where I wanted to go he
put his hand on the passenger seat
leaned back to me this one man it's hard
being a human being
what were you before this that's a
comparative statement you can't say that
unless you were something else that was
also more simple you know I was waiting
for a backstory didn't get what like
whoa man I was a six blacker Yoplait
yogurt
that was cool fruit on the bottom just
chilling I was a non-judgmental cactus
what's that man you know the tall ones
in the desert they're like hey man
whatever you're up to is cool done I do
I've conspiracy theories but my
conspiracy theories are so low rent
I can't even hang out with the actual
conspiracy theorists cuz they don't want
to entertain my notions I'm like the
Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer a
conspiracy theories there on the
clubhouse in the corner going over the
real stuff like of course the moon
landing was faked because we had to beat
Russia during the Cold War up there no
matter what the cost and I try and jump
in like yeah and I think that Trader
Joe's is making their parking lots too
small on purpose just so they seem more
popular than they really are
it's obvious that the mob killed Kennedy
and I think that expiration dates on
food are just a conspiracy by craft in
the FDA to get you to buy condiments
before you need to Manny's doesn't go
bad it just becomes Miracle Whip that's
a miracle a little extra tangy taste on
there and it's patience I'm sponsored by
Miracle Whip I might be getting too
paranoid though I'm probably alone on
this but I know I'm getting paranoid
I don't anybody else does this every
time I Drive by a Toys R Us I just
mutter to myself we sure are
I just watch Illuminati YouTube videos
for the rest of the day we've been a
lovely audience thank you very much
you